stand by me turns 30 on Monday and star
River Phoenix would have turned 46 on
Tuesday what was the most most difficult
thing about doing stuff as far as you
scenes that involve the motion and and
technical moves with the camera et was
with the late 80s heartthrob the week
the iconic movie first came out and just
one day after the late actor turned 16 I
have a lot of fun now and it's since
1886 he opened up about his role and how
his dad was just like his character bad
boy Chris Chambers he was trapped inside
of this reputation that that she was
born with and that's that he was one of
those chambers kids and he was like the
bad kid in town and he stole and he
didn't want to you know he he wanted to
you know climb above that and he just
couldn't this is a small town in
everyone to him how much of you is in
the character Chris besides my looks and
um
in a way I am kinda like a peacemaker
I'd say and I don't know much of me
isn't in the character but I know my dad
is in the character a lot because my dad
had the similar lifestyle that Chris had
my dad a kind of grew up in a small town
and he was like the bad kid juvenile
hall we went through all of that kind of
stuff
and he told me about all of it so in a
way I felt really close to Chris